[Music]
brandon is with us
in seattle hey hey hey brandon how are
you
hey i'm good thanks for taking my call
dave hey rachel hey what's up
hey so my question is uh if i should buy
a tesla if i don't
are you there oh no brandon
you're cutting in and out you're cutting
in and out you're still there
hey yes i'm still here okay i'm worried
about
you buying a high-tech tesla when your
phone doesn't work okay
um so
all right your question is can you buy a
tesla what
can i buy a tesla if i don't have a
house and i'm still like saving for a
house and in a few years probably want
to have a house
okay um well what's your financial
situation
uh yeah so my financial situation is uh
i guess income is around
240 k a year uh maybe 40
of that is in company stock um currently
like my debt is paid off so i have about
30 of that or maybe a little over
uh in a truck that i can sell to put
towards that
okay so you're gonna pay cash for a
tesla how much is the tesla that you're
looking at
uh so if you use so it'd probably be uh
maybe
around 60. okay well i don't
think it matters whether it's a tesla or
not can i can i
make 240 000 a year i'm single and i'm
completely debt free
and i have the cash to buy a 60 000 car
is that okay
yeah that's the question yeah i think
i'm single yes
nima i do have a girlfriend but i'm not
married yeah what's for me they've been
dating for a while so there could be
like expenses i guess for that too
well i'm just saying you know you don't
have uh you don't have children you have
a bunch of responsibilities you know
something else going on
you make a ton of money you're buying a
sixty thousand dollar car and you make
240 a year right
yeah okay rachel yeah do it brandon
i'm a little jealous tesla's kind of my
i'm not a car person
i'm impressed with tesla's i'm not gonna
lie so i i'm
i'm all for you get one financially
100 but i also think it's a really cool
car and i'm not a car person
so i think it's great yeah most tesla
people aren't car people
what does that mean it's the fastest car
on the road no but they're not car
people i mean it's so bad have you been
in of tesla before battery
no have you been in one of the battery
wait i'm being for real right now have
you been in one have you been in one
have you set and want to drive one
no i have not no i've not it's they
would have to
for me for me they would have to put an
app in there that had muffler noise
i have to hear something running to know
i'm in a car such a redneck
okay definitely definitely i own that
completely
you get in one and it's just there's
nothing got no loud mufflers
one big screen they're it's pretty
impressive i'm not gonna lie
so i think that's i think you know most
of the guys that i know that love them
are
are they're tech guys so and he's
seattle so i don't doubt it get your
testosterone
hey you cannot hate if you have not set
and drove in one
they come listen
oh man i forgot it now they call it some
kind of mode oh shoot
rocket mode no yeah it's called um
it's something you turn it on and you
put your foot on the gas you did it
and you you you did this you literally
you did the uh
the demo drive where they sell you no no
i didn't i didn't
completely sold you shoot it's called a
phrase
i forgot anyway it does have yeah i've
heard of this i've heard it it's part of
their demo it's insane
you literally have like vertigo you
literally feel like you've got your neck
i was with a guy last night that did the
new porsche the new battery porsche it's
not a tesla though
and uh no zero to zero to sixty and two
point nine he said i snapped this one
this is like
it's a battery car too it's the same
thing okay it's the new porsche battery
car
but yeah well anyways i can't talk
answer me this
here's what i don't understand okay i
got i got a thousand folks here
and we have like six or eight of those
plug-in things outside
yes and those plug-in things
to plug into the electric cars are on my
electric bill
oh that's smart of them i should bring
my tesla if i buy one here
so why is it that i don't have a gas
tank out there
to give free gas to the rest of people i
would assume it's way less expensive
although no no it's not
it's it's way less expensive for them
it's more expensive for me you would
save money on gas
i'm providing free fuel to some team
members but not to others
way more fair hey we're all on board
with that fyi yes
everybody in the booth wants a new gas
tank installed so we'll work on the epa
on that that's going to work
yeah i think it's much more inexpensive
to charge up the car
then it is for them no either way
if you know i don't
i just think it's interesting how that
culture work how that worked culturally
that i
no one ever thought that there was
anything wrong with me paying for that
it can't cost a lot i know but i'm not
griping about it it's just interesting
to me that
i'm supposed to do that culturally as
the
owner of the building i'm supposed to
provide electric for the electric cars
but the poor gas
people you know i don't i don't get it
it's just very interesting so
yeah get get you a tesla dude rachel
highly recommends
and put it in whatever that mode is that
she's talking about too
i know all the tesla i'm sure they'll be
tweeting oh i'll get worn out for days
over there sometimes
all right just give you one more thing
to be pissed off at david killer mode
i'm gonna have to google something else
listen i want something with a muffler
and
a big engine i can't even stand the fact
that that raptor has a little tiny six
cylinder in it
it's a tiny little six i had to put
booster i had to put
it yeah yeah see until you sit in one
and drive one
discussion i i have to admit that is a
valid argument i have not sat in one and
i have not driven one
and i do have good i have good friends
who are totally
geeked out about them it's fine i did
love that um malloy
when he spoke the guy's president of
ford called him a battery with wheels
ludicrous mode thank you kelly ludicrous
mode that's it
sounds like a rapper yes
this is the dave ramsey show